welcome Chris hi good morning how are
you great how are you guys good good
good man
you're almost lotus position but not
quite I like I like I said hi but it's
not to be dominant it's literally just
like you put my leg I'm kind of dominant
I found it awkward yeah you didn't feel
that you were being put in a submissive
position no but no guys do that when
they want to be higher up they think
it's a power position I just sure yeah
this book man I had no I do you have
done I don't know if you've purposely
kept a lot of these stories and and the
sort of darker things that happened to
you after SNL private or if it's just
they didn't come up because you weren't
talking about him in interviews or
whatever it was but there is most of the
time you know you people write these
books and for a guy like you I would
expect like okay we'll get some cool
behind-the-scenes SNL stories and then
maybe a nugget here there that we didn't
know right but I feel like almost
everything post SNL and certainly most
of your dating life that's in there all
that stuff is brand new to me yeah what
it is to most people and you know when
you write a book you know you're writing
about a lot of biography you write about
your life you know so there's a lot of
cathartic stuff you know you just go
through you know III didn't know my life
was as interesting as it was until I
went back and you know made uh just
started writing out what was what
happened in the events at first it was
just SNL stuff and then I realized
there's a lot more interesting things
you know going back for my childhood and
you know being in The Groundlings in LA
and trying to get on SNL and be honest
now and post S&L and just my life in
general and you know it's you know it's
a lot more interesting that I thought
and I was happy to know that how much
time did you spend with Colin Colin well
a lot I mean you know let's see I think
we're on this show a few seasons
together we were roommates actually so
or office mates rather and it was funny
I haven't says in the book too that he
he has he has a vertigo by the way I
don't know if you know that I actually I
know one ear is [ __ ] but I didn't know
he is very good yeah maybe I shouldn't
say that book
yeah the poor guy has vertigo and he
like they placed his desk right in front
of the window
like my desk was on the other side
facing the walls like you want to switch
like now that's fine
the poor guy the whole time he's just
dealing right in front of the windows
like a good Irish boy just deal yeah
just take it and yes suffer silently and
be miserable but he I was there when he
was a writer and then there when he was
doing Weekend Update he's one of the
nicest guys as you know so always I'm
always so interested in guys like Lauren
Michaels cuz there's really only a few
of them especially in entertainment that
have that kind of autonomy and and
almost certainly paternal in almost idol
worship from a lot of the people that
that work for them but it was really
interesting your story and your
relationship with them because you were
pretty it didn't seem like you were
honest about the fact that you've always
ordered the whole time you were there
looking for approval from him but when
you go over like when you get SNL it's
not Lorne Michaels saying that you've
got SNL it's Will Ferrell calling you
midseason and saying hey you want to
start next week so you didn't get this
ceremony where somebody calls you and
says Lauren Michaels loved your audition
and now you get to start it's just the
sort of weird random and then you get
there and they've already started so
you're kind of the fish-out-of-water and
you've just got to figure it out all the
way through until you you decide to
leave SNL mhm and the message that
Lauren is sad to see you go isn't coming
from Lauren you never get that opening
or closure or whatever it is from me
like why did we'll call you I think well
we'll call me cuz Lauren wanted will to
call me I mean it will did tell me that
so I don't think and I think that's how
a lot of things work I think in in show
business a lot a lot of people don't
want to make the call and they have
someone else call them for them on their
behalf in a way you know maybe because
they're overwhelmed with doing things I
don't know but um you know but in this
case we'll called me on behalf of of
Lauren and when I first got on the show
though I mean it was definitely coming
from Lauren obviously because that's how
I got hired of course and when I got on
the show I did a character called sue
Forrester who was a gibberish guy and
and he didn't get any laughs
at the read-through table but Lauren
trusted me and he put it in the show
anyway and in a guiding for it was the
first sketch of the night which was
fantastic for a feature player to get
that already and it wasn't for Lauren it
wouldn't have been you know he trusted
me completely so so there was that thing
like you felt like you had his trust
yeah like he he definitely was behind
getting me on obviously but he had will
do it because will was also you know
like my best friend he was my partner
you know we we did a lot of work
together in The Groundlings and I think
Lauren thought it would be probably a
lot of sketches that will and I would
have done together as well when we when
I get on SNL to join with him and what
is your relationship like with him at
this point
who we are in her will fell oh it's good
it's good it's very good it's a we're
friends and we text each other he's a
you know he's got you know he's got kids
he's a family guy I don't have kids so I
can't you know go to the soccer to meet
and sure see our kids play together kind
of thing barbecues be really awkward if
you did like it's like a family thing
I'm here to watch the game fan of the
sport I haven't read the book in it and
when I picked it up I just I was the
part I was reading I couldn't stop
reading it was about you and him kind of
having that weird thing after a night at
the Roxbury yeah
can you go into that a little bit just I
don't I'm not familiar with that history
a little bit because I want to save it
for the book it's written a lot there
let's see what can I say about well you
know Roxbury there was we were trying to
get Amy Heckerling to do the film and
Lauren Michaels was producing and there
was just a point where I basically got
into a relationship with Amy Heckerling
and and that kind of just stirred up a
little bit of I don't know I don't know
what happened but it was just a little
bit of a it was my fault for doing it
and I just kind of didn't say anything
about it and you know but but it was it
passed you know but did he date her he
did not date her no no not at all
no I did oh we were new to this the
movie industry and it may have come
across as I don't know it just may have
come across as I I was
trying to sleep you're way too late I
wait at the top even though I was
already at the same level right yes I
don't know I don't know what we had
whatever it was it was it felt kind of
like it's just because we're our team
you know and it was like we knew we said
we shared everything together and all
information were 100% we trusted each
other and then all of a sudden you know
I'm you know mess around with the
director and I think they just made it
made it uncomfortable I would never
bother me for I've worked with a friend
of mine again not on that level it was
just some awful thing we did but he
started talking the director and I
didn't care how good yeah yeah I just
wanted report it was it was just we were
new I mean the movie and it was a big
deal for us you know so any little thing
like that you know would be kind of like
you know disruptive I thought you would
be jealousy like when a guy like you
sorry develop gee when you and you're
that close to a guy do you have any
jealousy when he goes on to become you
know cuz he's bigger than most people is
there any kind of feeling of like
competitiveness or jealousy or hey could
you help me out here
no no I don't think so I don't you know
every so often maybe when I was younger
maybe you'd be like oh geez I wish I
could have you know done something you
know maybe I didn't make the right move
or something like that but I we have our
lives you know I have you know not
everybody I'm not saying well wills
wills it he's one of he's particularly a
happy healthy guy so I know that he is
in a good place but there are some
people as you know I don't know how JLo
is personally I mean at home maybe she's
not having the best time of her life
even though she's on top you know as you
know it what was it like for you always
the biggest greatest thing to be the
biggest star you know the eyes that's
like what was it like for you to as
mango get to wrestle
JLo for about I mean I was rewatching
that sketch that sketch last night and I
didn't remember I mean I remembered the
sketch but I didn't realize until I
rewatched it that you guys very
physically and closely yes wrestled for
like probably I mean four minutes it
wasn't 10 seconds there was a lot of
body contact going a lot and you were
scantily clad she was scantily clad and
it seemed like like for me watching it
yeah
I was like for Chris Kattan at the time
this must have been the greatest thing
in the world and it was it was
especially because her that week her
behind was we just got insured yeah I
don't remember that no but was inserted
like a Lloyds of London or something you
know what it was it was not a publicity
thing or did she have like worked I
think she really I don't know what she
was she was the first person who's
really famous for her ass yes at the
time one of them yeah very valuable at
the time it was valuable you know she
had to put insurance on it and so I got
to swat it that week which was fantastic
had a feel well I wouldn't be able to do
that now on television I don't know it
felt it was very firm yeah yeah it was
firm it wasn't my knee there's a firm
well built shape behind you have to say
when you were grappling cuz there and
seemed like there was some real
grappling going on did you get did you
get the sense that you know I wonder I
bet this woman could kick my ass I guess
she is she a muscular person or did you
feel like if it came down to it I would
I would win this I don't know I didn't I
don't usually think about that when it
comes to holding a woman can I take this
woman down yeah but because I'm not
usually that threatened at the moment
that were you at all worried and this
very pressure you might take me down are
you at all worried cuz I would be sure
when you're grappling with Jennifer
Lopez at the height of Jennifer Lopez
that there may be some physical signs of
excitement at the amount of body in
contact with a woman who looks like
Jennifer Lopez and I mean I would only
imagine
feels like Jennifer Lopez well were you
worried you would leak it would be more
like at the moment you like you're
you're full of adrenaline doing live
television so you're not thinking about
it uh-huh but if I were to watch the
sketch again and see that I'm touching
her maybe like a low-grade porn yes in
the moment you don't appreciate as much
as you like wow [ __ ] I really did that
but I was too worried about the right
cuz you're locked in you're you're lost
in your performance for committed for
the character how did how did Garth
Brooks feel about the mango character
I've always because I mean I remember
that also from you know when I was
watching and Garth Brooks came on is the
guest host and then I think he did like
Chris Gaines is your performance
well that's the second time he came on I
think I think so and the first time he
came on he yeah he was he was great you
know he played it
that's one of the best mango sketches
cuz he was so he was so absurd for Garth
Brooks of all people right to be
attracted to this mango character right
and he told me once though that he
people that that mango sketch became so
popular that at his concerts that people
would throw mangoes on stage where you
imagine that were you ever did you ever
try to angle for a mango movie cuz I
mean I don't know if people really
remember how popular the mango character
got like I mean for me I would say that
the mango character before the roxbury
movie mm-hmm if you just look at what
the Roxbury guys did on SNL and don't
take the movie into account whatsoever
right I mean the mango character in
terms of popular SNL characters for its
time was kind of on that level yeah it
was it was it was popular um but it was
uh wait what was the question
surprises compliment did there was ever
a or that there's never a mango Oh make
sure be there actually was when I was
doing that movie Corky Romano and one of
the Disney producers said are you
interested in doing like maybe a mango
movie with Disney and I thought like
yeah maybe but then I remember like my
mom this really wasn't it didn't really
like that character I wonder why I know
my mom and we weren't hot pants and but
you do know for me rotting my butt all
the time so I remember saying now maybe
we'll just hold off on it yeah I regret
that I I know I think it's fine I mean I
don't know you know it would have been
fun I don't regret it I I don't regret
anything really I
well maybe fruit there's a couple things
I regret but that's a hard question to
answer I think it would have been fun to
do yeah but it would definitely I think
at the time I was afraid of being
typecast as mango cuz a lot of every
characters I did people would typecast
you as that character were just weird
you know yeah did you uh did you be
voluntarily or was did they say hey look
how does and has the rain on SNL come to
an end I did I did leave voluntarily
they wanted me to stay which was a good
thing and it was eight years and I felt
that or seven a half years and I thought
that was a good run and also you know I
went on the show wanting to have
characters cuz that's how I thought like
would make me survive on the show you
know I didn't go on as a particularly
strong writer except for when it came to
characters I was good writing characters
and I thought like just like Mike Myers
if I had a few characters then that I
could be able to stay on the show for a
while you know and I just came out I
just ran out of manga light was there
any character you wanted to do like this
one is [ __ ] great but it just never
happened is there one who created that
they just you couldn't get a laugh with
I'm trying there was one oh let me see
others like oh no that was very funny
there's a guy called a coffee guy who's
just hopped up on coffee walked around
with a big pot of coffee going he was a
native man there's a lot of directions
to going with it didn't happen I've
always felt like the rocks first when
when mainstream started looking at him
and going like oh maybe he's more than a
wrestler was when he did SNL for the
first right has when he's a WWE guy I
think so no maybe that was the first
time he and I think you know and at
least in my mind's eye one of the big
skits that he did was peepers yes
because he you know as seen the rock
mm-hmm also do the peepers yeah do the
peepers gag if you was that something
you had to sell him on no he I think he
was into it I liked it yeah he was he's
really cool he's a super cool guy and he
was into it he didn't know exactly how
to eat the apple and dry hump hump
things on his own so he just followed me
well so you're kind of a player coach
yeah it comes to mr. peepers exactly
yeah but he's a you know really buff guy
obviously and got a lot of veins you
know popping out and he look in that
outfit you look like a big tall [ __ ] and
I look like a little penis when it's
true is it horrible and you when you
I'm always amazed you guys will do a
read-through in a you know in like a
room full of people and it's just bombs
right you got to commit to it and you
can't break how do you handle that can
you ever reap it something that just
tank and a read-through um you can reap
itch it and retry it it's funny to get
less laughs than it did the first time
so if it got no laughs the first time
it's gonna get
I don't know less than that um if that's
even possible but you know sometimes it
changes like I know like the Blue Oyster
Cult sketch was done a few times cowbell
and it got less and less laughs in the
read-through but it was chosen you know
for the Christopher Walken show so and
it's hard to you know you can't really
decipher how the audience will react
compared to the read-through so because
they don't know how many times it's been
you know good pitch for the read-through
so it becomes one of the most iconic
sketches of all time yeah you just never
know yeah yeah one of the I mean I I
think one of the key points in the book
in terms of post SNL life that I again I
didn't know and I don't think anybody
knew was that you broke your neck doing
SNL there was a sketch where you you
know you're always super physical you
throw yourself off a chair I throw up
myself
yes threw myself backwards right
backwards and you end up breaking your
neck yeah I injured myself yes you work
through the rest of the season because
you want to miss any episode correct and
you had to go through two surgeries well
five altogether altogether was five yeah
and that kind of led you into this place
where you were using painkillers true
yeah then you did you this is what I was
really curious about because on top of
painkillers you had for a period of time
a cocaine problem as well there was a
third time with that yeah that was a
while a long time ago right right but
and I only bring it up she talked about
in the book we can talk about that it
started after you dating Zooey Deschanel
yes it did did she know and and she she
goes on it's like the nightmare of
everybody you dating her everything's
going great she goes off to do a movie
and she goes you know what let's take a
break while I'm doing this movie cuz
it's a love story and you know and you
kind of know enough that well I didn't
know no I had no idea who was the
co-star but I don't even I forgot his
name Paul I
remember he was in I'm sorry I don't
remember his name he's a really good
actor but I didn't think that may happen
and I still don't know if anything
happened between the two I just know
that she being a really good actress
wanted to be open to you know anything
that may happen and she's probably being
very smart and safe about everything I
hold to you the fact that she did in
advance before well how long were you
together to me and yeah even though I
was heartbroken was that a new
relationship it was not like a wild out
that you only went out for a few months
ago thing but I was like head over heels
with her you might imagine story to show
do you fall in love quick I do yeah yeah
I mean I don't know if I'm one of those
love addicts somebody said I might be
yeah yeah but well I depends when you
got somebody do you find yourself as
soon as you got them and it's secure do
you find yourself wanting to cheat and
text other people no well I feel like
more like let's get a puppy oh you want
to stay with him and okay okay it might
pass my relationships I usually we
usually would you know move in together
kind of thing pretty quickly
I never definitely you know what live
with no it's really great is it yeah
it's fantastic plus you're not married
yet and so there's no like you know but
how much does the move out shot nothing
wrong with the marriage but to move out
oh it's terrible it's not fun you know
it's kind of like that's the only
usually every relationship I was in was
pretty mutual you know there may be one
or two that weren't um that were pretty
heartbreaking but um yeah no I
definitely fall in love I've been single
for a while to it it's like I used to be
a bit of a relationship [ __ ] you know
just like hop from one relationship to
the other and have very little time
alone in between but I've actually been
out of a really haven't been in a
relationship for like maybe almost two
years now
do you feel healthier for the thing that
you could function without a
relationship well so I think so yes what
I'm supposed to feel so yeah I used to
feel like unable to function without
being in a relationship like yeah I had
to be in a relationship do you panic
though at all as you get older cuz I'm
getting older you start like a [ __ ] man
there's no long term kind of looking
around like I'm gonna do something well
I am you know I'm 48 so I want to I
would like to be back in a healthier
relationship at some point you know
someone that's healthy and and and
supportive and
and we have the same aspirations and
dreams and stuff like that you know it
does not be the same dream but you know
what I mean like someone someone that's
you know we get along you're on the same
wavelength exactly yeah no totally be
nice I don't want to stay you know I
don't want to be I like to get I would
like to get married and have a kid or
something do you nice did Joey know how
heartbroken you were does she know now
because you talked about in the book
that that's kind that you tried cocaine
for the first time right after you guys
broke up because they're just so
destroyed yeah that's what that mean
yeah I wanted to feel I didn't want to
feel heartbroken so I was like I need to
try something I need to do something
yeah so but I didn't you know it was um
wish it did help a little bit yeah
cocaine will put you in a better mood of
time but uh you know it was um but it
wasn't her fault obviously it was my
choice right to do that afterwards but
um I don't know what you get back with
her or no no no you know Dale okay no I
think I think she's probably thought I
was a little little nuts
a little crazy because I want to get
back together and I was like obsessed
about wondering is she not gonna come
back and you know that kind of thing ah
sure probably got a little coach
advocate she's a pro you know I mean
he's a pro about it and being very
respectful I mean if I were in her shoes
I'd do exactly what she did and that was
like you know I'm doing a movie I don't
know what's gonna happen you know and I
just think it's smart to move on right
now through any because you seem like
you're in a really healthy space right
now and that's why now would probably be
the time to put this book out because
you can tell these stories in the right
headspace you don't want to be in a
wrong headspace and write the book right
because then it becomes bitter and it
becomes like nasty instead of just going
like hey this is my life it's pretty
wild right right right
um did you at any point like in your in
your darker times did you look at SNL is
less of a blessing and more of a curse
in the sense that while it was your
dream and you got to live your dream it
also broke your neck
I mean certainly a blessing know I had
you never know so you never went through
that bitter space for well no I I was
you know I was embarrassed about my
injury and I want to keep going and I
was very it was humiliating and
you know you have a you know you just
you're debilitated and your arm is being
atrophied and then yep surgeries and
it's just something you don't want to be
seen doing you know your physical
comedian you know you don't want to be
like look at me I have a neck brace on
and I'm walking around with a walker
which happened those four years of my
life you know and that's what set me
back a big big deal you know
and but no I wouldn't trade it for the
world my time on us to know was
fantastic and Lauren was good to me and
you know during that time and I mean
just with my characters and you know I
had a wonderful time on SNL
how'd you before we let you go Sonny you
have to leave they're telling you to
leave did you leave Travis is telling us
to put his fingers on fire
did you rehearse to fall back on the
chair or did I something you decided to
do or was that part of the sketch where
you had to fall back it was um no I I
rehearse it I just didn't give it my all
yet you know but I I you could see in
telling the book that I asked the chair
to be replaced and it wasn't replaced
which is you know but ultimately it's my
fault you know I'm not saying nobody's
negligent nobody's negligent reliable
you know I chose to do that stunt but
and that just happens that's just happen
the injury just happened to be during
that sketch on that so no there's also I
mean for those that are curious about I
mean I love when people are honest about
their movies sure you have a whole
chapter about what happened with Corky
Romano and what it started as where it
ended up as which I thought was great
oh good thing I do you have a do you
have a favorite character of the
characters that you did on SNL I
actually yeah I don't if you remember
there was a sketch called goth talk yeah
yeah and she was Cersei nightshade and I
was as rail abyss and I looked a lot
like Robert Smith from the Cure uh-huh
and I my voice was like I was like I'm
Azrael abyss I'm the Prince of sorrow
and I were just Cinnabons yeah and I
like that yeah it's pretty one of my
favorites great one more Jim and Sam
catch up with full episodes and
interviews from celebrity guests anytime
demand using the SiriusXM app